the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
talking about most of our time talking
about new jargon that were using but the
main goal is to take a binary decision
yes and no all right so just so that
we're clear and we make sure that we all
speak the same language let me just
remind you what the key words are for
test right so the first thing is that we
split theta and theta naught and theta 1
both are included in theta and they're
disjoint ok so I have my set of possible
parameters and then I have theta naught
this here theta 1 is here and there
might be something that I leave out okay
and so what we're doing is we have two
hypotheses so here's our hypothesis
testing problem and it's h0 theta
belongs to theta 0 versus h1 theta
belongs to theta 1 this guy was called
the null and this guy was called the
alternative and why we give them special
names is because we saw that they have
an asymmetric role the null presents the
status quo and data is here to bring
evidence against this guy and we can
really never conclude that h0 is true
because all we could conclude is that h0
h1 is not true ok or or may not be true
ok so so that was the first thing the
second thing was the hypothesis the
third thing is what is a test well sigh
it's a statistic
and it takes the data and it maps it
into zero or one okay and I didn't
really mention it but there's something
such as called randomized test which is
well if I cannot really make a decision
I might as well flip a coin that tends
to be biased but that's really I mean
think about it in practice you probably
don't want to make decisions based on
flipping a coin and so what people
typically do this is happening typically
at one specific value so rather than
flipping a coin for this very specific
value what people typically do is they
say okay I'm gonna side with h0 because
that's the most conservative choice I
can make
all right so in a way they think of
flipping this coin but always falling on
heads
alright so associated to this test was
something called well the rejection
region Arps I which is just the set of
data x1 xn such that Phi of X 1 xn is
equal to 1 so that means we reject h0
when the test is 1 and those are the set
of data points that actually are going
to lead me to to reject the test
okay then the things that we're actually
slightly a little more important and
really peculiar to to test specific to
test where the type 1 and type 2 error
alright so the type 1 error arises when
so type 1 error is when you reject
whereas a zero is correct and the type 2
error is the opposite so it's fail to
reject whereas each one is correct okay
so those are the two types of errors you
can make and we quantify their
probability of type 1 error all right so
alpha psy is the probability so that's
the probability of type 1 error so
besides just the probability for theta
that psy rejects and that's for defined
for theta and theta not alright so for
different values of theta not right so
h0 being correct means there exist of
theta in theta 0 for which that actually
is the right different distribution
right so for different values of theta I
might make different errors okay so if
you think for example about the coin
example if if I'm testing if the coin is
biased towards heads or bias towards
tails right so if I'm testing whether P
is larger than 1/2 or less than 1/2 then
when the true P let's say our h0 is
larger than 1/2 when P is equal to 1
it's actually very difficult for me to
make a mistake right because I only see
heads okay so when P is getting closer
to 1/2 I'm gonna start making more and
more probability there ok and so the
type 2 error so that's
probability of type 2 is denoted by beta
sy and it's the function well that does
the opposite and this time is defined
for theta in theater not in theta 1 okay
and finally we define something called
the power PI sign this time this is
actually a number and so this number is
is equal to the maximum over theta and
theta naught I mean that could be a
supreme M but think of it as being a
maximum of P theta of sy is equal 3
that's in 0 right anyone sex would know
that's sorry that's the min okay so this
is not making a mistake right there Anat
is in H in theta 1 so if theta is in
theta 1 and I conclude one so this is a
good thing I want this number to be
large and I'm looking at the worst house
what is the smallest value this number
can be okay so what I want to show you a
little bit as a picture okay so now I'm
gonna take theta and think of it as
being a P okay so I'm gonna take P okay
for some Vernonia experiments so P can
range between 0 and 1 that's for sure
okay and what I'm gonna try to test is
whether P is less than 1/2 or larger
than 1/2 okay so this is gonna be let's
say theta naught and this guy here is
theta 1 the strength to give you a
picture of what those guys are okay so I
have my y-axis
now I'm gonna start drawing numbers all
these things this function this function
and this number are all numbers between
0 & 1
okay
so now I'm claiming that so when I move
from left to right what is my
probability of rejecting gonna do okay
so what I'm gonna plot is the
probability under theta the first thing
I want to plot is the probability and
their theta that sly is equal to one
okay and let's sips I think of sy as
being just you know this indicator that
square root of n xn bar minus P over
square root X n bar one minus xn bar is
larger than some constant C four
appropriately chosen C okay so what we
choose is that C's in such a way that at
one half when we're testing for one half
what we wanted was this number to be
equal to alpha basically okay so we
fixed this alpha number so that's this
guy so if I want sy alpha of sigh of
theta less than alpha given in advanced
so think of it being equal to say 5
percent so in fixing this number and I
want this to be controlled for all theta
and theta naught okay so if you're gonna
give me this budget well I'm actually
gonna make it equal where I can okay if
you're telling me you can make it equal
to alpha we know that if I increase my
type 1 error I'm gonna decrease my type
2 error right if I start putting
everyone in jail or if I start letting
everyone go free right that's what we're
discussing last time so since we have
this trade-off and you're giving me a
budget for one guy I'm just gonna max it
out okay and where am I going to max it
out exactly a 1/2 at the boundary okay
so this is going to be 5%
okay so what I know is that since alpha
of theta is less than alpha for all
theta and theta not sorry that's first
data not right that's where alpha is
defined so for theta and theta naught I
know that my function is going to look
like this it's going to be somewhere in
this rectangle everybody agrees okay so
this function for this guy is going to
look like this when I'm at zero when P
is equal to zero which means I only
observe zeros that I know that P is
going to be zero and I will certainly
not conclude that P is equal to one
right
this test will never conclude that P is
equal to one
sorry that was yeah that p is equal to
so that pees or than one-half just
because xn bar is going to be equal to
zero okay well this is actually not well
defined so maybe I need to do something
put it equal to zero if xn bar is equal
to zero
so I guess basically I get something
which is negative and so it's never
going to be larger than what I want and
so here I'm actually starting at zero so
now this is this function here that
increases I mean it should increase like
smoothly this function here is alpha sy
of data or a flop size P let's say
because we're talking about P okay then
it reaches alpha here now when I go on
the other side I'm actually looking at
beta right when I'm on theta one the
function that matter is the probability
of type two error which is beta psi and
this beta psi is actually going to
increase so beat up sy is what well bit
ups I should also sorry that's the
probability of being equal to alpha so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna look at
the probability of rejecting okay so let
me draw this function all the way it's
gonna look like this okay now here if I
look at this function here here this is
the probability and there theta that sy
is equal to one okay and we just said
that in this region this function is
called a supply in that region it's not
called alpha boy it's not called
anything this is the probability of
rejection okay so it's not any error
it's actually what you should be doing
what we're looking at in this region is
one - this guy right we're looking at
the probability of not rejecting so I
need to actually basically look at one
minus this thing which here is going to
be 95% so I'm gonna do 95% and this is
my probability and I'm just basically
drawing the symmetric of this guy okay
so this here is the probability under
theta that sy is equal to 0 which is 1
minus P theta that sy is equal to 1
right so it's just 1 minus the white
curve okay
and it's actually by definition equal to
beta psi of theta okay now where do I
reach pipes I
what is pops pipes I on this picture its
pops I a number or a function it's a
number right it's the minimum of a
function what is this function it's the
probability under theta that theta is
equal to one I drew this entire function
for between theta zero and theta one
right I drew this is this entire white
curve this is this probability now I'm
saying look at the smallest value of
this probability can take on the set
theta one
what is this this guy this is where my
pie this thing here is PI sy and so it's
equal to five percent so that's for this
particular test because this test has
sort of a continuous curve for this pie
and so if I want to make sure that I'm
at 5% when I come to the right of theta
zero if it touches theta one then I
better have 5% on the other side if the
function is continuous all right so
basically if this function is increasing
which will be the case for most tasks
then what's going to happen is that an N
continuous then what's going to happen
is that the level of the test which is
alpha is actually going to be equal to
the power of the test okay now there's
something that he didn't mention and you
know I'm just mentioning it that's it by
here I define the power itself this
function this entire white curve here is
actually called the power function this
thing that's the entire white curve and
what you could have is tests that have
the entire curve which is dominated by
an another test right so here if I look
at this test and let's assume I can
build another test that has this curve
that's it's the same here but then here
it looks like this
okay what is the power of this test it's
the same it's 5% because this point
touches here exactly at the same point
however for any other value than the
worst-possible this guy is doing better
than this guy can you see that having a
curve higher on the right-hand side is a
good thing because it means that you
tend to reject more when you're actually
in h1 okay so this guy is definitely
better than this guy and so what we say
in this case that is that the test with
the dashed line is uniformly most more
powerful than the other test but we're
not going to go into those details
because basically all the tests that we
will describe are already the most
powerful ones okay in particular this
guy is there's no such thing all the
other guys you can come up with are
gonna actually be below okay so we saw a
couple tests and we saw how to pick this
threshold and we define those two things
okay yes
yeah because you're given this budget of
5% right so in this paradigm where
you're given that actually any if the if
the dashed line was this light dashed
line I would still be happy I mean I
don't care what this thing does here as
long as it's below 5% but here I'm gonna
try to discover right think about again
the drug discovery example you're trying
to find let's say you're scientist and
you're trying to prove that your drug
works what do you want to see well FDA
puts on your own you this constraint
that you're type 1 error should your
probability of type 1 error should never
exceed 5% you're gonna work under this
assumption but what you're gonna do is
gonna try to find a test that will make
you find something as often as possible
and so you're gonna Mack this constraint
of 5% and then you're gonna try to make
this curve this curve that means that
this is basically this number here for
any point here is the probability that
you publish your paper all right that's
the probability that your mark you can
release to market your drug that's the
probability that it works right and so
you want this curve to be as high as
possible you want to you know make sure
that if there's evidence in the data
that h1 is the truth you want to squeeze
as much of this evidence as possible and
the test that has the highest possible
curve is the most powerful now you have
to also understand that having two
curves that are on top of each other
completely everywhere is a rare
phenomenon right it's not always the
case that there is a test that's
uniformly more powerful than any other
test it might be that you have some
trade-off that it might be better here
but then you're losing power here maybe
it's I mean things like this well
actually maybe it should not go down but
let's say it goes like this and then
maybe this guy goes like this right then
you know you have to basically make an
educated guess whether you think that
the theta you're gonna find is here or
it's here and then you pick a test okay
any other question yes
so the green curve is exactly right so
that's beta upside of theta so it's the
it's really the type 2 error and it's
defined only here right so here it's not
it's not a definition it's really just
I'm just mapping it to this point right
so it's defined only here and it's the
probability of type 2 here okay so here
it's pretty large right I'm making it
basically as large as I could because
I'm at the boundary and that means at
the boundary since the status quo is a
zero I'm always gonna go for a zero if I
don't have any evidence which means that
what's gonna pay it's the type 2 error
that's going to basically pay this okay
any other question all right so let's
move on okay so did we do this so I
think we stopped here right dude I
didn't cover that part okay so as I said
in this paradigm we're gonna actually
fix this guy to be some thing and this
thing is actually called the level of
the test I'm sorry this is again more
words actually good news is that we
split into two lectures so we have you
know what is the test was it a
hypothesis whether what is the null what
is the alternative what is the type 1
error what is the type 2 error and now
I'm telling you there's another thing so
we define the power which was some sort
of a lower bound on the under or it's 1
minus the upper bound on the type 2
error basically and so it's alternative
so that's the power is the smallest
probability of rejecting when you're in
the null and its alternative when you're
in a Teta one right so that's my power I
looked here and I looked at the smallest
value and I can look at this side and
say well what is the largest probability
that I make a type 1 error again this
largest probability is the level of the
test okay so
so this is alpha equal by definition to
the maximum for theta and theta not of
alpha sine theta okay so here I just put
the level itself as you can see here it
essentially says that if I'm of level 5
percent I'm also at level 10 percent I'm
also of levels 15 percent so here it's
really an upper bound whatever you guys
want to take this is what it is but as
we said if this number is five is four
point five percent you're losing in your
type two here so if you're allowed to
have if this maximum here is four point
five percent and FDA told you you can go
to five percent you're losing in your
type 2 here so you actually want to make
sure that this is the five percent
that's given to you okay so the way it
works is that you give me the Alpha then
I'm gonna go back pick C that depends on
alpha here so that this thing is
actually equal to five percent okay and
so of course in many instances we do not
know the probability we do not know how
to compute the probability of type one
error right this is a maximum value for
the probability of type one error we
don't know how to compute it I mean it
might be a very complicated random
variable maybe it's a weird binomial we
could compute it but it would be painful
but what we know how to compute is it's
a synthetic value which is because of
the central limit theorem convergence
and distribution tells me that the
probability of type one error is
basically going towards the probability
at some gaussian is in some region okay
and so we're gonna compute not the level
itself but the synthetic level okay and
that's basically the limit as n goes to
infinity of alpha sine of theta and then
I'm gonna make the max here okay
so how am I going to compute this well
if I take a test that has rejection
region of the form T and because it
depends on the data right that's T n of
X 1 X and my observations larger than
some numbers C ok of course I can almost
always write tests like that except that
sometimes there's gonna be an absolute
value which essentially means I'm going
away from some value maybe actually I'm
less than something but I can always put
a negative sign in front of everything
so this is not without much of
generality right so this includes
something that looks like you know
something is larger than the constant
right so that means which is equivalent
to well let me write it as T Q ok
because then that means that so that's T
n but this actually encompasses the fact
that QN is larger than C or QN is less
than C and n minus C so that includes
this guy that also includes QN less than
C because this is equivalent to QN is
larger than minus C and minus QN is
looking so that's gonna be my TM right
so I can actually I can actually encode
several type of things
okay rejection regions that so here in
this case I have a rejection region that
looks like this or a rejection region
that looks like this or rejection region
that looks like this okay and here I
don't really represent it for the whole
data but maybe for the average for
example or the normalized average
okay so if I write this then yeah and in
this case this TN that shows up
it's called test statistic I mean this
is sort of I mean this is not like set
in stone here for example Q could be the
test statistics they don't have to be
minus Q itself that's the test statistic
right so what is the test statistic well
it's what you're gonna build from your
data and then compare to some fixed
value alright so in the example we had
here what is our test statistic well
it's this guy right this was our test
statistic okay and is this thing
statistic what is that what are the
criteria for a statistic
what is the statistic I know you know
the answer yeah it's a measurable
function of the data that does not
depend on the parameter is this guy a
statistic let's think again
when I implemented the test what did I
do
I was able to compute my test my test
did not depend on some unknown parameter
how did we do it we just plugged in
point five here remember that was the
value for which we computed it because
under h0 that was the value we're seeing
and if theta zero is actually an entire
set I'm just gonna take the value that's
the closest to which one we'll see that
in a second I mean I did not guarantee
that to you but just taking the worse
type one error and bounded by alpha is
equivalent to taking P and taking the
value of P that's the closest to the to
H 1 to theta 1 which is completely
intuitive right the worst type 1 error
is going to be attained for the P that's
the closest to the alternative so even
if the alternate even if the null is
actually just an entire set it's as if
it was just the point that's the closest
to the alternative okay so now we can
compute this because there's no unknown
parameters that shows up we replace P by
0.5 and so that was our test statistic
okay so when you're building a test you
want to first build a test statistic and
then and then see what threshold you
should be getting okay so now let's go
back to our example where we want to
have we have x1 xn there iid Bernoulli P
and I want to test it P is one half
versus P not equal to one half which as
I said is what you want to do if you
want to test if if a coin is fair okay
and so here I'm gonna build a test
statistic and we concluded last time
that what do we want for this test
statistic we want it to have a
distribution which under the null does
not depend on the parameters a
distribution that I can actually compute
quintiles of
all right so what we did is we said well
if I look at the central limit theorem
tells me that square root of n xn bar
minus P divided by so we figure central
limit theorem plots let's keep for
example I'm gonna have square roots okay
and we've had this discussion whether we
want to use that's key or not here but
let's assume we're taking Slutsky
wherever we can so this thing tells me
that by the central limit theorem as n
goes to infinity this thing converges in
distribution to some n 0 1 ok now as we
said this guy is not something we know
but under the null we actually know it
and we can actually replace it by 1/2 so
this thing holds under h0 when I write
under h0 it means when this is the truth
okay so now I have something that
converges to something that has no
dependence on anything I don't know and
in particular if you have any statistics
textbook which you don't because I
didn't require one you should be
thankful because this thing's costs $350
these things actually if you look at the
back you actually have a table for a
standard Gaussian I could have anything
else here I could have an exponential
distribution I could have a I don't know
I will see the chi-square distribution
in a minute right any distribution from
which you can actually see a table that
somebody actually computed this thing
for which you can actually draw out a
PDF and start computing whatever
probability you want on them then this
is what you want to see at the right
hand side okay this is any distribution
it's called pivot all right I think
we've mentioned that before
pivotal means it does not depend on
anything that you don't know and maybe
it's easy to compute those things
probably typically you need a computer
to simulate them for you because
computing probabilities for gaussians is
not an easy thing we don't know how to
solve those integrals exactly we have to
do it numerically
okay so now
I want to do this test my test statistic
will be declared to be what well I'm
gonna reject if what is larger than some
number the absolute value of this guy
okay so my test statistic is gonna be
square root of n minus 0.5 divided by
square root of xn bar 1 minus xn bar
that's my test statistic absolute value
of this guy because I want to reject
either when this guy is too large or
when this guy is too small right I I
don't know ahead whether I'm gonna see P
larger than 1/2 or less than 1/2 so now
I need to compute C such that the
probability that TN is lower than C so
that's what that's the probability under
P which is unknown
I want this probability to be less than
some level alpha asymptotically okay so
I want the limit of this guy to be less
than alpha and that's the level of my
test so that's the given level okay so I
want this thing to happen now what I
know is that this limit actually I
should say given asymptotic level okay
so what is this thing well okay that's
the probability that's something that
looks like under P so under P this guy
so what I know is that TN is square root
of n minus xn bar minus 0.5 divided by
square root of xn bar 1 minus xn bar
exceeds okay is this true that as n goes
to infinity this probability is the same
as the probability that the absolute
value of a Gaussian exceeds see I have a
standard Gaussian it's this true
yeah the absolutely so so you're saying
that this as n becomes large enough this
should be the probability that some
absolute value of n 0 1 exceed C right
so I claim that this is not correct can
tell somebody tell me why even in the
limit it's not correct so what do you
see exactly right so we picked this
point 5 here but this is for any P right
but what is the only P I can get so what
I want is that this is true for all P in
theta naught but the only P that's in
theta naught is actually P is equal to
0.5 so yes what you said was true but it
required to specify P to be equal to 0.5
so this in general is not true but it
happens to be true if P belongs to 10 or
not which is strictly equivalent to P is
equal to 0.5 right because Tina naught
is really just this one point 0.5 okay
so now this becomes true
and so what I need to do is to find C
such that this guy is equal to what I
mean just let's just follow right so I
want this to be less than alpha but then
we say that this was equal to this which
is equal to this so all I want is that
this guy is less than alpha but we said
we might as well just make it equal to
alpha if you allow me to make it as big
as I want as long as it's less than
alpha so so this is a true statement but
it's if under this condition right so
I'm gonna set it equal to alpha and then
I'm gonna try to solve for C
okay so what I'm looking for is a C such
that if I draw a standard Gaussian okay
so that's PDF of some n01 I want the
probability at the absolute value of my
Gaussian exceeding this guy
so that means being either here or here
so that's minus C and C I want the sum
of those two things to be equal to alpha
okay so I want the sum of these areas to
equal alpha so by symmetry each of them
should be equal to alpha over two and so
what I'm looking for is C such that the
probability that my n01 exceeds C which
is just this area to the right now
equals alpha which is equivalent to
taking C which is Q alpha over two
equals alpha over 2 and that's Q alpha
over two by definition of Q alpha over
two that's just what Q alpha over two is
and that's what the tables at the back
of the book give you as anybody who has
already seen a table for no Gaussian
probabilities alright what it does is
just the table I mean it's pretty
ancient right I mean of course you can
actually ask Google to do it for you now
you could it's basically standard issue
but back in the day they actually had to
look at tables and since the values
alphas were pretty standard right the
values alpha that people were requesting
were typically 1 percent 5 percent 10
percent all you could do is to compute
these different values for different
values of alpha that was it ok so that's
really not much to do okay so for the
Gaussian I can tell you that alpha is
equal to you know if alpha is equal to
five percent then Q alpha over 2 Q 2.5%
is equal to 1.96 okay so those are just
fixed numbers that are functions of the
Gaussian alright so everybody agrees
we've done that before for for our
confidence intervals and and so now we
know that if I actually plug in this guy
to be Q alpha over 2 then this limit is
actually equal to alpha and so now I've
actually constrained this okay so Q
alpha over 2 here is 4 alpha equals 5%
as I said is 1.96 so in the example 1
the number that we found was 3.54 I
think or something like that 3-point
5540 right so right so if we scroll back
very quickly 3.45 that was example1
example2 negative point 77 so if I look
at T and in example 1 TN was just the
absolute value of 3 point 45 which don't
pull out your calculators is equal to 3
point 45 example 2 absolute value of
negative point 77 was equal to 0.7 t 7
and so all i need to check is this
number larger or smaller than 1.96
that's what my test ends up being okay
so in example 1 3.45 being larger than
1.96 that means that I reject fairness
of my coins in example 2.77 being
smaller than 1.96 what do I do
I fail to reject
okay okay
so here's a question in example one for
what level alpha would sigh alpha what
is this the the the okay so here but
what's gonna happen if I start
increasing my level
sorry decreasing my level alright when I
decrease my level I'm actually making
this area smaller and smaller which
means that I push this C to the right
okay so now I'm asking what is the
smallest C I should pick so that now I
actually do not reject h0 what is the
smallest sia should be taking here what
is the smallest C so see here in the
example I gave you for five percent was
1.96 what is the smallest C I should be
taking so that now this inequality is
reversed three point four five I asked
only trivial questions don't be worried
okay so three point four five is the
smallest see that I'm actually willing
to tolerate right so maybe so let's say
this was my five percent if this was a
two point five if alpha here let's say
in this picture alpha is five percent
that means maybe I need to push here and
this number should be what so this is
going to be 1.96 and this number here is
gonna be three points forty five okay
clearly to scale and so now what I need
to what I want to ask you is well
there's two ways I can understand this
number 3.45 it is the number 3.45 but i
can also try to understand what is the
area to the right of this guy and if I
understand what the area to the right of
this guy is this is actually some alpha
prime over two and that means that if I
actually fix this level alpha prime that
would be exactly the tipping point
at which I would go from accepting to
rejecting right so I know in terms of
absolute thresholds 3.45 is the trivial
answer to the question that's the
tipping point because I'm comparing a
number to 3.45 but now if I try to map
this back and understand what level
would have been giving me this
particular tipping point that's a number
between 0 & 1 the smaller the number the
larger this number here which means that
the more evidence I have in my data
against h0 and so this number is
actually something called the p-value
okay and so same for example - there's
the tipping point alpha at which I go
from failing to reject rejecting and
that's exactly the number the area under
the curve such that here I see point 77
and this is this alpha prime prime over
2 and this number is clearly alpha prime
prime is clearly larger than 5% so
what's the advantage of thinking and
mapping back these numbers well now I'm
actually gonna spit out some number
which is between 0 & 1 and that should
be the only scale you should have in
mind remember we discussed that last
time I was like well if I actually spit
out a number which is 3 point 45 maybe
you can try to think what is 3.45 a
large number for a gaussian right that's
the number but if I had another random
variable that was not Gaussian maybe it
was a double exponential you would have
to have another scale in your mind is
3.45 a large number for the a large so
large that it's unlikely for to come
from a double exponential if I had a
gamma distribution I can think of any
distribution and then that means for
each distribution you would have to have
a scale in mind so of course you can
have the Gaussian scale in mind I mean I
have the caps in scale in mind but then
if I map it back into this number
between 0 & 1 all the distributions play
the same role so whether I'm talking
about if my limiting distribution is
normal or exponential or gamma or
whatever you want
for all these guys I'm just going to map
it into one number between zero and one
small number means lots of evidence
against h1 large number means little
evidence again ah sorry lots of evidence
against h0 small number means very few
evidence against the extra h0 and this
is the only number you need to keep in
mind and the question is - am I willing
to tolerate this number between 5
percent 6 percent or maybe 10 percent 12
percent and those this is the scale the
only scale you have to have in mind and
this scale is the scale of p-values all
right so the p-value is the tipping
point in terms of alpha in words I can
make it formal because tipping point as
far as I know it's not a mathematical
term so a p-value is the of a test is
the smallest potentially asymptotic
level if I talk about it asymptotic
p-value and that's what we do when we
talk about central limit theorem at
which the test rejects h0 if I were to
go any smaller sorry it's the smallest
level yeah if I were to go any smaller I
would fail to reject right the smaller
the level the less likely it is for me
to reject and if I were to go any
smaller I would start failing to reject
okay and so it is a random number right
it depends on what I actually observe
right so here of course I instantiate
those two numbers 3.45 and 0.7 77 as
realizations of random variables but if
you think of those as being the random
numbers before I see my data this was
exactly this was a random number and
therefore the area to the under the
curve to the right of it is also a
random area okay this thing's fluctuates
then the curve the area under the curve
fluctuates and that's what the p-value
is that's what is his name forget John
Oliver talks about when it talks about P
hack okay and so we talked about this in
the first lecture
alright so P hacking is how do I do if
I'm a scientist do I want to see a small
p-value or a large p-value small right
scientists want to see small
values because small P values equals
rejecting which equals discovery which
equals publications which equals
promotion all right so that's what
people want to see so so people are
tempted to see small P values and what's
called P hacking is well find a way to
cheat maybe look at your data formulate
your hypothesis in such a way that you
will actually have a smaller p-value
than you should have all right so here
for example there's one thing I did not
insist on because again this is not a
particular question in statistical
thinking but one thing that we
implicitly did was set those about those
theta 0 and theta 1 ahead of time ok I
fixed them and I'm trying to test this
this is to be contrasted with the
following approach I draw my data
alright so I draw I run this experiment
which is probably going to get me a
publication in nature I'm trying to test
this if a coin is fair and I draw my
data and I see that there's 13 out of 30
of my observations that are heads okay
that means that from this data it looks
like P is less than 1/2 so if I look at
this data and then decide that my
alternative is not P not equal to 1/2
but rather P less than 1/2 that's P
hacking I'm actually making my p-value
strictly smaller by first looking at the
data and then deciding what my
alternative is going to be and that's
cheating ok because all the things we
did were assuming that this point 5 or
the alternative was actually a fix
everything was deterministic the only
randomness came from the data but if I
start looking at the data and designing
my experiment or my alternatives and all
hypothesis based on the data it's as if
I started putting randomness all over
the place and then I cannot control it
because I don't know how it just
intermingles with each other all right
so that was for the john oliver moment
ok so the p-value is nice so maybe I
mentioned that before my wife works in
market research and
maybe every two years she seems to run
into a statistician in the hallway and
she comes to and say what is the p-value
again and for her a p-value is just the
number isn't in an Excel spreadsheet and
actually small equals good and large
equals bad and that's all she needs to
know at this point actually they do the
job for her small is green large is red
and so for her a p-value is just green
or red okay and but so what she's really
implicitly doing with this color code is
just applying the golden rule what the
statisticians do for her in the Excel
spreadsheet is that they take the
numbers for the P values that are less
than some fixed level so depending on
the field in which she works so she
works from other so-called companies so
the P values are typically compared the
tests are usually perform at level one
percent rather than five percent okay so
five percent is maybe your gold standard
if you're doing you know sociology or
trying to
I don't know release a new you know
blueberry flavor for your toothpaste
like something that's not like gonna
change the life of people maybe you're
gonna run at five percent it's okay to
make a mistake see people are just gonna
feel gross but that's about it
all right whereas whereas here if you
have this p-value which is less than 1%
might be more important for some drug
discovery for example and so let's say
you run at phat 1% okay and so what they
do in this Excel spreadsheet is that all
the numbers that are below 1% show up in
green and all the numbers that are above
1% show up in red and that's it that's
just applying the golden rule if the
number is green reject if the number is
red fail to reject okay yeah
you mean my by achieving my goal you
mean put letting it ethics aside right
you want to be published so I'm okay so
let me teach you how so well here what
do you do you want to at the end of the
day a test is only telling you whether
you found evidence in your data that
each one was more likely than zero
basically how do you make h1 more likely
well you just basically target h1 to be
what it is what the data is gonna make
it more likely to be alright
so if for example I say h1 can be on
both sides then you know my data is
gonna have to take into account
fluctuations on both sides and I'm gonna
lose a factor to somewhere because
things are not symmetric here's the
ultimate way of making this work I'm
going back to my example of flipping
coins and now right so here what I did
is that I said oh this number point 43
he's actually very is actually smaller
than point five so I'm just gonna test
with around point five or I'm less than
0.5 but here's something that I can
promise you I did not make the
computation will reject okay so here
this one actually yeah this one feels to
reject right so here's one that will
certainly reject h0 is 0.5 P is 0.5 H 1
P is 0.4 T 3 okay now you can try but I
can promise you that your data will tell
you that H 1 is the right one
okay I mean you can check very quickly
that this is real
extremely likely to happen right and so
actually what am i no actually it's not
true okay because here the test that I
derive that's based on this kind of
stuff right here at some point somewhere
under some layers I assume that all our
tests are gonna have this form but here
this is only when you're trying to test
one region versus another region next to
it or one point versus and region around
it or something like this whereas for
this guy there's another test I could
come up with which is what is the
probability that I get point 43 and what
is the probability that I get point 5
now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna just
conclude it's whichever has the largest
probability then maybe I'm gonna have to
make some adjustments so that the level
is actually 5% but I can make this
happen I can make the level be 5% and
always conclude this guy but I would
have to use a different test now the
test that I described again those TN
larger than C or bill tend to be tests
that are sort of resilient to this kind
of manipulations because they're sort of
oblivious towards what the alternative
looks like I mean they're just saying
it's either to the left or to the right
but whether it's a point or an entire
half line doesn't matter okay so if you
try to look at your data and just put
the data itself into your hypothesis
testing problem then you're you're
failing there the the statistical
principle that's what people are doing
right I mean how can I check I mean of
course here it's gonna be pretty blatant
if you publish a paper that looks like
this but there's ways to do it
differently right for example one way to
do it is to just do mold so typically
what people do is they do multiple
hypothesis testing they're doing you
know 100 tests at a time then you know
you have random fluctuations every time
and so they just pick the one that has
the random fluctuations that go their
way I mean sometimes going in there your
way and sometimes going the opposite way
so you just pick the one that works for
you we'll talk about multiple hypothesis
testing soon if you want to increase
your publication counts all right
[Music]
there's actually papers the thing it was
big news some papers in psychology or
psychiatry expand purse that actually
refused to publish p-values now all
right where were we
okay here's the Golden Rule so one thing
that I like to show is this thing just
so you know how you apply the golden
rule and how you apply to standard test
right so the standard paradigm is the
following you have a black box which is
your test right that's for my wife that
this is the fourth floor of the building
this where the statisticians sit what
she sends there is data let's say X 1 X
N and she says well you know this one is
about toothpaste so here's a level
okay let's define what the fourth water
brings back is that answer yes no green
red just an answer all right so that's
the standard testing you just speeded
the data and the level at which you want
to perform the test may be asymptotic it
spits out a yes/no answer what p-value
does you just speed it the data itself
and what it spits out is the p-value and
now it's just up to you I mean hopefully
you have your brain has the
computational power of deciding whether
a number is larger or smaller than 5%
without having to college statisticians
for this all right and that's what it
does so now we're all in one skill now
if you actually you know I see some of
you nodding when I talk about P hacking
so that means you've seen p-values if
you've seen more than 100 p-values in
your life you have an entire scale a P a
good p-value is less than you know 10 to
the minus 4 that's the ultimate sweet
spot all right actually software
statistical software spit out an output
which says less than 10 to the minus 5
and but then
maybe you want to pivot if I tell you my
p-value was you know if you tell me my
p-value was 4.65
and then I will say you've been doing
some pee hacking until you found a
number that was below 5%
all right that's typically what people
will do but you know if you tell me if
you if you're doing the test if you're
saying I published my result my test at
5% said yes that means that maybe your
p-value was point was 4.99 or your
p-value was 10 to the minus 4 I will
never know and we'll never know how much
evidence you had against the null but if
you tell me what the p-value is I can
make my own decision I don't have to
tell me whether it's a yes/no you tell
me it's 4.90 I'm gonna say well you know
maybe yes but I'm gonna take it with a
grain of salt all right then so that's
why p values are good numbers to have in
mind now I show it as if it was like you
know an old trig that you start
mastering when you're 45 years old no
it's just how small is the number
between 0 and 1 that's really what you
need to know ok maybe on the log scale
if it's 10 to the minus 1 10 to the
minus 2 10 to the minus 3 etc that's
probably the that's probably the extent
of the mastery here all right
so this traditional standard paradigm
that I showed is actually commonly
referred to as the neyman-pearson
paradigm all right so here it says name
and Pearson's theory so there's an
interior an entire theory that comes
with it but it's really a paradigm it's
a way of thinking about I pathes is
testing that says well if I'm not gonna
be able to optimize both my type 1 and
type 2 error I'm actually gonna lock in
my type 1 error below some level and
just and just like maximize minimize the
type 2 error under this constraint
that's what the neyman-pearson paradigm
is and it sort of makes sense for
hypothesis testing problems if you were
doing some other applications with multi
objective optimization you would maybe
come up with something different for
example machine learning is not
performing typically under
neyman-pearson paradigm alright so if
you do spam filtering you could say well
I want to constrain the probability as
much as I can of taking somebody's
important emails and throwing them out
as spam and under this constraint not
send too much
and that person you know that sort of
makes sense for spams now if you're
labeling cats versus dogs it's probably
not like you want to make sure that no
more than five percent of the dogs that
are labeled cat because I mean you know
it doesn't matter so what you typically
do is you just sum up the two types of
error you can make and you minimize the
sum without putting any more weight on
one or the other
all right so here's an example we're
doing a binary decision one or two or
the errors you can make you don't have
to actually be like that so this example
here I did not the trivial tests I is
equal to zero was it what was it in the
in the US trial court example what is I
equals zero that was concluding always
to the null what was the null innocent
right that's the status quo so that
means that this guy never rejects a zero
everybody's going away free so you're
sure you're not actually going against
you know the Constitution because alpha
is zero percent which is certainly less
than five percent but the power the fact
that a lot of criminals go back outside
and the free world is actually
formulated in terms of low power which
in this case is actually zero and the
power it's a number between zero and one
close to zero good close to one bad now
what is the definition of the p-value
that's gonna be something it's a
mouthful right the definition of the
p-value is a mouth ball it's really you
know it's the tipping point it is the
smallest level at which bla bla bla bla
bla right it's complicated to remember
it now I think that by my six
explanation my wife after saying oh so
it's the probability of making an error
I said yeah that's the probably I make
an error because of course you know she
can think make probability of making an
error small good large bad right so you
know that's actually a good way to
remember I'm pretty sure that at least
fifty percent of people who are using
p-values out there thing
that the p-value is the probability of
making an error now for all matters of
purposes if your goal is to just
threshold the p-value this is okay to
have this in mind but when comes at
least until December 22 I would
recommend trying to actually memorize
the right definition for the p-value
okay okay so so the idea again is you
know fix the level and try to optimize
the power all right
so we're gonna try to compute some
p-values from now on okay how do you
compute the p-value well you can
actually see it in a from this picture
over there all right one thing I didn't
show on this picture so here was my Q
alpha over two that had alpha here alpha
over two here right that was my Q alpha
over two and I said if I'm to the right
of if TN is to the right of this guy I'm
gonna I'm gonna reject if TN is to the
left of this guy I'm gonna fail to
reject okay
pictorially you can actually represent
the p-value it's when I replace this guy
by TN itself sorry that's p-value over
two if it actually that's p-value so let
me just keep it like that and put the
absolute value here okay so if you
replace the role of Q alpha over two by
your test statistic this is what the the
area under the curve is actually the
p-value itself up to scale because of
the symmetric thing okay so there's a
good way to see pictorially what the
p-value is it's just the probability
that some gaussians this is the
probability that's some absolute value
of n zero one exceeds TN right that's
what the p-value is now this guy has
nothing to do with this guy so this is
really just you know 1 minus the
Gaussian CDF of TN and that's it so
that's how I would compute p-values now
as I said the p-value is a beauty
because you don't have to under
stand the fact that you're limiting
distribution is a Gaussian right it's
already factored in this construction
the fact that I'm actually looking at
this cumulative distribution function of
a standard Gaussian makes my p-value
automatically adjust to what the
limiting distribution is and if this was
the cumulative distribution function of
a exponential I would just have a
different function here at the denoted
by F for example and I would just
compute a different value but in the end
regardless of what the limiting value is
my p-value would still be a number
between 0 and 1 and so to illustrate
that let's look at other weird
distributions that we could get in place
of the standard Gaussian and we're not
going to see many but we'll see one and
it's not called the chi-squared
distribution it's actually called a
student's distribution but it involves
the chi-square distribution as a
building block so I don't know if my
fanatics are not really read there so I
try to say well it scared so for a
positive integer right so there's only
one parameter rights over the Gaussian
you have two parameters which are mu and
Sigma squared those are real numbers
Sigma square positive here I have one
integer parameter okay then the
distribution the chi-square distribution
with D degrees of freedom so the
parameter is called a degree of freedom
just like nu is called the expected
value in Sigma square is called the
variance here we call it degrees of
freedom you don't have to really
understand why okay so that's the law
that you would get that's the random
variable you would get if you were to
sum d squares of independent standard
gaussians okay so I take the square of
an independent random Gaussian I take
another one I sum them and that's a
chi-square with two degrees of freedom
okay that's how you get it now I could
define it using its it's probability
density function right I mean after all
this is the sum of you know positive
random variables so it is a positive
random variable it has a density on the
positive
your wine and you know the PDF of
chi-square PDF of chi-squared with D
degrees of freedom is what well it's F D
of X is what is it X to the D over 2
minus 1 e to the minus x over 2 and then
here I have a gamma of G over 2 and the
other one is I think 2 to the D over 2
minus 1 to the D over 2
okay that's what it is okay that's the
density if you were very good at
probability you can make the change your
variable and write your Jacobian and do
all this stuff and actually check that
this is true I do not recommend doing
that ok so this is the density but it's
better understood like that I think it
was just some thing that you built from
standard Gaussian so for example an
example of a K square with two degrees
of freedom is actually the following
thing let's assume I have a target like
this and I don't aim very well and I'm
trying to I'm trying to hit the center
and I'm not gonna have maybe a deviation
which is standard Gaussian left right
and standard Gaussian north-south okay
so I'm throwing and then I'm here and
I'm claiming that this number here by
Pythagoras theorem the squared distance
here is the sum of this squared distance
here which is the square of a Gaussian
by assumption this is plus the square of
this distance which is the square of
another independent Gaussian I assume
those are independent and so the squared
distance from this point to this point
is the Chi square with two degrees of
freedom okay so this isn't this guy here
is n 0 1 squared this is n 0 1 squared
and so this guy here this distance here
is K squared with two degrees of freedom
I mean the squared distance I'm talking
about squared distances here okay
so now you can see that actually
Pythagoras is basically why k-square
arise right that's why it has its own
name I mean you know I could define this
random variable I mean it's actually you
know a gamma distribution I could it's a
special case of something called the
gamma distribution the fact that the
special case has its own name is because
there's many times where we're gonna
take some of squares of independent
gaussians because gaussians the sum of
squares is really the norm the Euclidean
norm squared just by Pythagoras theorem
right if I mean higher dimension I can
start to some more squared coordinates
and I'm gonna measure the norm squared
okay so if you want to draw this picture
it looks like this again it's the sum of
positive numbers so it's going to be on
0 plus infinity that's FD and so for f
one looks like this if two looks like
this so the the tails becomes heavier
and heavier as G increases and then it
start to three search to have a
different shape it starts it starts from
zero and it looks like this and then as
the increases it's basically as if you
were to push this thing to the right
right it's just like all right you're
just is just following like a big bowl
okay everybody sees what's going on so
there's just this fat thing is just
going there what is the expected value
of a K square so it's the expected value
of the sum of Gaussian random variables
squared
which is in those are n01 yeah yeah
which is D okay so one thing you can
check quickly is that the expected value
of a chi-square is D and so you see
that's why this the mass is shifting to
the right as D increases it's just going
there actually the variance is also
increasing the variance is 2 D okay so
this is one thing and so why do we care
about this in you know basic statistics
it's not like we're actually have
statistics much about throwing darts at
high dimensional boards so what's
happening is that if I look at the
sample variance right the average of the
sum of squared centered by their mean
then I can actually expand this as the
sum of the squares minus the average
price is the same thing that we have the
same trick that we have for the variance
second moment - first moment square and
then I claim that Cochrane's theorem and
I will tell you in a second what
Cochrane's theorem tells me is that this
sample variance is actually so if I had
only this so now okay look at those guys
those guys are Gaussian with mean mu and
variance Sigma square think for one
second new being zero and and Sigma
square being one now this part would be
a chi square with n degrees of freedom
divided by n now I get another thing
here which is the square of something
that looks like a Gaussian as well so it
looks like I have something else here
which looks also like a chi square now
Cochran theorem is essentially telling
you that those things are independent
and so that in a way you can think of
those guys as being here n degrees of
freedom minus 1 degree of freedom now
here as I said this is not mean 0 and
variance 1 the fact that it's not mean 0
is not a problem because I can remove
the mean here and remove them
here and so this thing has the same
distribution regardless of what the
actual mean is so without loss of
generality you can assume that nu is
equal to zero now the variance I'm gonna
have to pay because if I multiply all
these numbers by 10 then this SN is
going to be multiplied by 100 so this
thing is going to scale with the
variance and not surprisingly it's
scaling like the square of the variance
so if I look at SN it's distributed as
Sigma squared times the Chi square with
n minus 1 degrees of freedom divided by
N and we don't really write that because
a Chi square times Sigma square divided
by n is not a distribution so we put
everything to the left and we say that
this is actually a chi square with n
minus 1 degrees of freedom okay so here
I'm actually dropping a fact on you but
you can sort of see the building block
right what is the thing that's sort of
fussy at this point but the rest should
be crystal clear to you the thing that
fussy is that removing this squared guy
here is actually removing one degree of
freedom that should be weird but that's
what Cochrane's theorem tells me it's
essentially stating something about
orthogonality of subspaces with the span
of the constant vector or something like
that okay so you don't have to think
about it too much but that's what it's
telling me but the rest if you plug in
so the scaling in Sigma squared and in n
so that I should be completely clear to
you
so in particular if I remove that part
it should be clear to you that this
thing if mean is zero this thing is
actually distributed what well if mu is
zero what is the distribution of this
guy so I removed that part right just
this part
so I have X I which are n 0 Sigma
squared and I'm asking what is the
distribution of 1 over n sum from I
equal 1 to N of X I squared so it is the
sum of their iid so it's the sum of
independent gaussians but not standard
so the first thing to make them standard
is that I divide all of them by Sigma
squared ok now this guy is of the form Z
I squared where Zi is n 0 1 ok so now
this thing here has what distribution
chi squared end and now Sigma squared
over N times K squared and so if I have
Sigma squared divided by n time a chi
squared sorry so n times this divided
the times n divided by Sigma square so
if I take this thing and I multiply it
by n divided by Sigma square means I
remove this term and now I am left with
a chi square with n degrees of freedom
now the effect of centering with the
sample mean here is only to lose one
degree of freedom that's it ok so if I
want to do a test about variance since
this is supposedly a good estimator of
variance
this could be my pivotal distribution
this could play the role of a Gaussian
if I want to know if my variance is
equal to 1 or larger than 1 I could
actually build a test bathe on this only
statement and test if the variance is
lower than 1 or not now this is not
asymptotic because I started with the
very assumption that my data was gas in
itself ok now just a side remark you can
check that this Chi square to 2 is an
exponential with half degrees of freedom
which is certainly not clear from the
fact that Z 1 squared plus Z 2 squared
is a chi square with two degrees of
freedom right if I give you the sum of
the square of two independent Gaussian
this is actually an exponential that's
not super clear right
but if you look at well what's here I
don't know if you took note but let me
rewrite it for you so who is X to the D
over 2 minus 1 e to the minus x over 2
divided by 2 to the D over 2 gamma of D
over 2 gamma so if I plug in D is equal
to 2 gamma of 2 over 2 is gamma of 1
which is 1 right factor of 0 so it's 1
so this guy goes away 2 to the D over 2
is 2 to the 1 so that's just 1 no that's
just too ok then X to the D over 2 minus
1 is X to the 0 goes away and so I have
X minus X over 2 1/2 which is really
indeed of the form lambda e to the minus
lambda ax 4 lambda is equal to 1/2 which
was our exponential distribution okay so
well next week is well Columbus Day so
next next Monday so next week we'll talk
about students distribution and so that
was discovered by a guy who pretended
his name was student but was not student
and I challenge you to find Y in the
mean time all right so I'll see you next
week your homework is going to be
outside so we can realize the room